vous savez en ukraine l'allemagne n'a
pas une très bonne image en ce moment du
fait de son refus d'envoyer des armes a
le crâne est aussi son interdiction aux
pays baltes de vendre des armes de
production allemande à l'ukraine et
aussi du refus de love shop de confirmer
clairement que le gazoduc nordstream 2
n'entrera pas en opération
tant que cette situation avec la russie
ne sera pas résolu en réalité les
ukrainiens sont contre north stream 2d
son inception ils ont organisé une lobby
très forte aux états unis notamment pour
que encourager les uns états unis à
appliquer des sanctions contre ce
gazoduc qui pour les ukrainiens et
complètement pas nécessaire puisque la
capacité des gazoducs qui passe par
l'ukraine est largement suffisante selon
les ukrainiens pour fournir l'europe
avec tous ses besoins en gaz russe pour
les ukrainiens c'est un projet
géopolitique qui vise justement à priver
l'ukraine de ses revenus du transport du
gaz est aussi selon certains ukrainien
pour rendre plus facile à la russie deux
hommes envahir l'ukraine ou de procéder
à une militaire à une action militaire
en ukraine sans mettre en danger ses
propres les gazoducs qu'elles utilisent
pour acheminer son gaz vers l'europe
donc aujourd'hui les ukrainiens voudrais
enfin entendre de la bouche ce que notre
hymne de ne sera pas opérationnel si la
russie attaque l'ukraine sinon ils
savent que la chance va leur dire qu'il
faut continuer à essayer de négocier sur
la base du protocole de minsk pour la
résolution du conflit dont le dôme basse
les ukrainiens sont d'accord avec ça il
faut continuer à négocier ce qu'ils ne
veulent pas entendre ce serait des
pressions de la part des allemands pour
que dans le cas du processus de minsk
qui il négocie directement avec les
soi-disant séparatiste dont une base
qu'ils considèrent comme illégitime et
des marionnettes de la russie en gros
les ukrainiens ne voudrais pas appliquer
le processus de minsk selon les la
manière l'interprétation de vladimir
poutine et si les allemands leur met la
pression pour faire plus de concessions
en ce sens je pense que la réponse de
kiev sera tout simplement non bonjour
gulliver pour autant l'allemagne comme
d'autres pays occidentaux à commencer
par avec les états unis appelle ses
ressortissants à quitter l'ukraine à
kiev on évoque ces heures ci une
possible fermeture de l'espace aérien
qu'est ce qu'on en pense là où vous êtes
la fermeture de l'espace aérien s'était
dit fais des assureurs qui ne voulaient
pas assurés les compagnies aériennes qui
volerait au dessus de l'ukraine la
réponse du gouvernement ukrainienne a
été de mettre en place un fonds d'une
valeur d'environ 600 millions de dollars
pour garantir les pertes potentielles t
compagnies aériennes pour pas qu'ils
arrêtent de survoler l'ukraine klm a
déjà arrêté les vols vers ce pays on va
voir quelle sera la réaction des autres
compagnies aériennes aujourd'hui c'est
quelque chose qui met les ukrainiens en
colère ils disent c'est comme si c'était
nous qui étions sous le coup des
sanctions et par la russie c'est
l'économie ukrainienne à cause de cela
et de nombreux autres facteurs qui
souffrent plus que celle de la russie en
ce moment à cause de cette crise et puis
bien sûr aussi ça fait monter le niveau
de tension quoi qu'il en soit le fait
que des compagnies aériennes
internationales arrête de voler vers ton
pays clairement ça inquiète et pour
rajouter encore à cette inquiétude il y
a eu plus de 20 jets privés et charters
qui sont partis de kiev hier dimanche
c'est donc les riches les oligarques du
pays qui ont décidé que le moment est
venu de partir et ça clairement certains
ukrainiens se demande si ces oligarques
beaucoup d'entre lesquels ont des liens
assez proche avec la russie savent
quelque chose qu'eux ils ne savent pas